[Musique]
c'était le 23 janvier dernier il fait
très froid allée verte autour de -20 la
nuit est calme à la résidence du havre
la plupart des 54 résidents dorment
profondément mais à 00h22 l'alarmé
incendie du bâtiment et déclenché une
minute trente plus tard la centrale
9-1-1 téléphone d'urgence le gardien de
nuit pour nos boulangers qui demande des
pompiers sur place
à peu près au même moment mario michaud
qui habite en face de la résidence
contact lui aussi le 9 1 1
déjà selon son témoignage le feu faisait
rage à la candeur du bâtiment dans le
premier cas tout neuf à 00h 19m temps à
peu près signal d'alarmé madame répond
je me dis que trois minutes et demie
après la première alarme à 00h26 ce
premier message est envoyé à l'équipe b
et quelques secondes après à l'équipe à
des pompiers de l'isle verte
il s'agit de pompiers à temps partiel
qui coache eux et non à la caserne
toutes les communications se font partie
les avertisseurs
à 00h29 sept minutes après la première
alarme da centrale 9-1-1 reçoit un appel
qui ne laisse aucun doute sur la gravité
de la situation il est écrit sur la
carte d'appel autres appels reçus pour
des pompiers incendie fumer à
l'intérieur ne sont pas capables
d'évacuer ce qui signifie que des gens
sont prises à l'intérieur
pour un des deux seuls rescapés de la
vieille partie de la résidence du havre
conrad morin 89 ans c'est le début du
cauchemar jugé le manager ce marché
jamais réveillé il pleut juste un siège
auquel je participe au rez-de-chaussée
par le lait la porte du portage pc
portable à portée chaude et puis
possibilité de poser par le cg
virilement puis j'ai pas d'eau chaude
qu'elle est
[Musique]
à la centrale 9-1-1 on modifie la
procédure d'urgence par un changement de
code
69 des 0 1 p ce qui signifie feu
confirmé au risque vital personnes
coincées à l'écrit
est-ce que jus des flammes
oui dans tout ça j'en vois le vrai que
j'ai voulu les femmes oubliées 25 voix
jeanne mim puis je vends des filles bien
là restait 1 minute 102 sél alerte
générale pour délit verte
la quinzaine de pompiers sont à nouveau
appelés pour se rendre d'urgence sur les
lieux
thiam en et ça c'est des bouffées par
l'embauché de ceux ci c'est un incident
majeur de sa partie de ses invités et
puis ça vous voyez ça doit vouloir du
sud fut pendant que le feu fait rage
les pompiers sont engagés dans une
véritable course contre la montre dans
des dépositions des pompiers dont
enquête obtenu copie le pompier yann
charron le fils du chef raconte mon
badge est à sonner à 00h27 00h30 et
00h34 je suis alors parti à la course je
suis passé sur la passerelle sur la rue
saint-jean-baptiste puis sur la rue
rouleau et finalement sur la 132 jusqu'à
la résidence du off
un autre jeune pompier simon lavoie
ajoute j'ai reçu l'appel à 00h23 je me
suis habillé j'ai embarqué dans mon auto
je me suis stationné près de la 132 je
voyais des personnes qui criaient sur
les balcons les flammes monter assez
haut
parce qu'elle voulait le possible
passage c'est pour aller chercher ma
femme qui fait mouche au troisième
pilote au premier partiel des poèmes
puis amélie les vip au tandem de bruits
de marché et est ce que vous avez
téléphonie avez vous criez nous j'ai
pesé le fallait pas que je me suis posée
des droits
et puis librement qu'ils aient fait que
j'ai eus coup de rabot le chef yvan
charron a déclaré dans sa déposition
remise aux enquêteurs après la tragédie
qu'il n'a pas reçu l'appel d'alarmé
générale d' incendies pour un bâtiment à
haut risque vital sur le code que l'on
voit ce n'est qu'un 00h31 huit minutes
après le début du feu qui communiquent
par téléphone avec la centrale 9-1-1
la préposée l'informent qu'il ya
vraiment des flammes et de la fumée
dès qu'on ne réussit pas à évacuer les
résidants
malgré ces informations le chef sharon
ne demande pas immédiatement des
renforts des municipalités avoisinantes
une erreur selon l'ancien chef pompier
et robert kirby qui a formé des pompiers
partout au québec pendant une vingtaine
d'années
il a aussi dirigé des pompiers tant en
milieu urbain que rural souvent à haut
risque avec beaucoup de personnes
humaines dedans puis la centrale
d'alarmé leur dis qu'il ya des personnes
coincées qui n'était pas sorti chez vous
que tu as dit avis la centrale je veux
sur so so so so so so sur la scène
le feu continue de prendre de l'ampleur
les résidents crie à l'aide
ils sont prisonniers des flammes des
voisins sortent leur échelle pour
essayer de les sauver
le soleil était ça sortait de partout et
qu'il faut c'est ma mère quand il va
fouiller les à-côtés l'échelle je vais
monter monter dans l'échelle monte plats
à mi-chemin l'oeil à saint philippe
viard voler avec un morceau de
couverture qui a tombé en feu jaccottet
de mouiller il continue pareil quand
j'arrivais à sa porte et l'opacité vous
passez ou leurs inquiétudes et se dirige
d'un pas mais elle te cru sauver l'été à
respirer plus l'eau pendant les dix
minutes qui suivent la première
communication du chef charron le centre
d'appels continue de recevoir des appels
de voisins désespérée la situation est
de plus en plus critique
les préposés de la centrale 9-1-1
multiplié les interventions en demandant
d'urgence des ambulances
des courriels sont envoyés au
coordonnateur de la prévention de la mrc
mais toujours pas de demande de renforts
ce n'est qu'à minuit 40 18 minutes après
la première alarme qu'un premier camion
pompe arrivent sur place
combien après vous avez vos premiers
pompiers arrivés à peu près j'irais ne
tienne de menottes matin j'étais combien
je sais pour à peu près tous unis ctu
est de sartène et manille met autant ils
vont bien enlevé la course tels que les
autres ça a percé d'un biseau paris
ce que c'est long oui le top 6 loto pops
et ada municipalité main mais c'est long
parce que selon les normes là dessus au
dessus du ministère de la sécurité
publique à 15 minutes
là c'est ce que ça commençait très très
lent 15 noeuds richard gauthier ancien
capitaine des services d'incendié à la
ville de montréal vit aujourd'hui dans
la région de l'île verte
il est formateur aussi en analysant la
chronologie des événements il y voit un
problème d'organisation
léo en arrive qu'ils semblent pas avoir
de plan d'intégration chirurgien
interventions çà me tenir rigueur des
excédents après l'os en vo fut l'un des
sites qu'on va chercher à pareil on vit
ce butin serait une grosse perte de
temps chaque minute de retard dont je
veux comme celui-là devient critique
conrad murray le sait très bien il est
il lui même chef pompier pendant vingt
ans dans les petites communautés de
saint louis du ha ha dans témiscouata
est ce qu avait des pompiers moi je me
souviens d'arrivée j'ai deux pulls
faisait au point où vous et ça nous a
réveillés
ce n'est toujours pas en vue ces scans
avec jeannette où il ne vais vous l'avez
entendu après le temps du quinze jours
ils reposaient dans les instants
suivants à 00h41 la carte d'appel
indique que le chef charron demande
finalement l'entr'aide soit l'aide de
pompiers volontaires de deux
municipalités
cette loi est sympa de la croix est un
peu plus tard de ceux de saint-arsène
[Musique]
je m'interroge sur les délais d'appel là
dessus c'est parce que ces vélos
attendait juste là tels qu'ils ont roulé
catinot sus si vous regardez les appels
d'entre eux est tous les deux quand tu
es devant la petite voix de la
provocation ce fait mais ton entraîne
n'est pas sur les lieux mais ça marche
europe aux environs 40 minutes après le
début du feu le coordonnateur de la
prévention des merci christian chénard
ye qui habite rivière-du-loup arrive il
déclara sa déposition
j'aidais yvan qu'on allait gérer
l'intervention à 2 il m'a dit oui posé
avec moi on a besoin d'être 1h25 plus
tard le poste de commandement mandera
l'aide des pompiers de trois pistoles
est encore plus tard de cacouna de une
seconde est située à environ 20
kilomètres de l'île verte
surtout pour protéger le village de la
propagation
il est trop tard pour sauver des vies
mais jamais le plus gros service des
incendies de la région celui des
lumières du loup qu'un longue échelle et
qui suit à 28 km ne sera appelé le chef
moment l'eau doit être classées en puce
ion comme vous ils y arrivent sur les
lieux il fait une analyse la situation
s'est fait rapidement et ensuite de
touba il place son poste de commandement
en fait
à l'extérieur du bâtiment de façon à
recevoir les pompiers qui vont arriver
pour les obliger
et puis ce moment là les envoyer à
différents secteurs dans ce qu ici il
faut le tout était
homogène pour donner pour faire
d'évacuation fait et desseauve table
quand même 32 morts en attendant les
pompiers des municipalités avoisinantes
des situation s'aggrave
le pompier jean guy côté raconte dans sa
déposition je voyais pas la douleur
il y avait beaucoup de ligue 1 la
visibilité était nulle
le bâtiment était pas accessible le
pompier ghislain thériault poursuit
sortait des gens sur des chaises par
dessus la clôture le préventionniste
christian chénard gay témoigne j'ai vu
un cadavre pas de jambes ni bord le
pompier la voie ajoute je suis rentré à
l'intérieur avec yvan charron
je ne voyais pas jusqu'à l'autre bout du
corridor j'avais de la difficulté à
respirer
on a sorti toutes les personnes que nous
avons pu sortir
le chaos semblait régner dans
l'intervention des pompiers une source
nous a déclaré que c'était le free for
all le bordel qu'on ne pouvait pas
communiquer avec le chef yvan charron
qui avait décidé de pénétrer dans le
bâtiment pour sauver des gens ce dernier
parle dans sa déposition que tumulte il
décide d'entrer dans le bâtiment sans
son appareil respiratoire pour tenter de
sauver des vies il l'a confirmé dans une
entrevue à tva kg de manquer d'air
j'ai sorti mais j'ai jamais une pratique
qui n'est pas conseillé selon le chef
kirby ils entendent d'empiéter commandé
par la fumée python dans le corridor
mais qu'est-ce qui va diriger les
opérations puis aussi de l'extérieur
vous avez tout le portrait de qu'est ce
qui se passe ou plus fort de la bataille
le capitaine jean yves julie raconte la
porte intérieure était baril j'empêche
qu'on défonce la porte pour éviter une
draft
ça criait sur le balcon sauvez nous
d'une source bien au fait de ce qui
s'est passé cette nuit là se demande
encore pourquoi la porte principale
était barré alors qu'une alarme devrait
la déverrouiller beaucoup de victimes
auraient été retrouvés à cet endroit
j'ai pas vu passer en force il l'entrée
principale juste en face il y avait des
corps mutilés par des gens ainsi être
fait par la porte principale
plusieurs problèmes soit en alimentation
en eau ou avec les équipements sont
survenus durant la nuit le
préventionniste chez narguer raconte
j'ai su que la borne fontaine est à son
maximum mais j'ai fait quand même se
raccorder tu demandais à deux pompiers
de saint pol et saint-eloi de le faire
mais m'ont répondu qu'ils savaient pas
faire ça qui connaissait post s'est fait
partie sud commence
comment brancher un camion d'incendié à
une baleine bonne fontaine fait partie
du pays au bord de la formation le
pompier c'est la job fonds tennis
le pompier provencher poursuit j'ai
voulu brancher un tuyau 2 pouces et demi
pour saint-eloi sur la borne 34 mais il
n'y avait pas de robinet de valve le
lieutenant appétit de loup ajoute je ne
pouvais pas communiquer car mon radio ne
fonctionnait pas
sans compter le fait que certains
pompiers sont arrivés tard sur les lieux
un de ceux là raconte ma conjointe m'a
réveillé à une heure car mon pas jade
sonné
dans une autre déposition on peut lire
mon page est stationné à 00h33 j'étais
très endormi je ne me suis pas levé le
mercredi j'avais été en formation toute
la journée et j'avais pris un somnifère
en couchant c'est en me levant à 6h15
que j'ai pris l'information à lcn
je me suis habillé et je me suis rendu
sur le site je me sentais mal
ce membre du service des incendies de
l'isle-verte disait se sentir mal bien
que la disponibilité des pompiers
volontaires au québec ne soit pas
obligatoire
puis ces choses-là ce jeu les pauvres et
cupidon pdb mais mon personnel non plus
quand le ça sonne le téléavertisseur
sonne ces gars là sont entraînés
pictures pour rouler à une fois trois
fois l'ajax à noiron sa femme le
réveiller à 1h l'autre poste doit sa
richesse sa de dépôt d'un monde
au total ce sont une cinquantaine de
pompiers qui ont combattu le violent
incendie de la résidence du havre
survenu le 23 janvier dernier
pendant toute la nuit la centrale 9-1-1
a multiplié les interventions auprès des
pompiers des policiers de la sûreté du
québec et des ambulanciers monsieur
conrad murray un des seuls à avoir
survécu dans les vieilles partie de la
résidence a été gravement blessé il s'en
est sorti par miracle vous à tomber les
hommes il y avait été très déçu mais
j'ai sorti puisque vous êtes brisée et
un membre ou un si vous avez une
fracture navy seal cette fracture il
serait super il dut joubin lige du 13 tu
viens me sauver j'ai vu que j'ai pas eu
d'arrêt
je souffrais de marché ne serait ni d'un
régime et même plus même les gens que
damon et puis mestré nil ce pour mille
en effet j'ai négocié un coût que le
monsieur tu me connais c'est par ici
si monsieur mari je veux juste faire un
people j'ai parlé du mire il je me
rappelle pas les ambulants je m'appelle
orange et me suis réveillé à l'aube
stage qu'un diop que mon linge vous avez
failli mourir
[Musique]
j'ai même changé rapporte que peut-être
les deux images les plus les jauges les
la carte d'appel indique qu'à 5 heures
du matin les pompiers sont encore en
combat des situations comme à elles
stabilisées
ils ne peuvent pas encore déclarée un
10/10 soit la maîtrise du feu qu'il y
ait encore des personnes manquantes
à 12h37 le chef des pompiers a déclaré
finalement le 10 10 les opérations de
recherches pour retrouver les corps des
disparus commence notamment pour
retrouver la femme de monsieur conrad
morin morte dans sa chambre
plus d'un tiers des flammes tu vas te
faire mal au point cette chance le rêve
non les lots quand j'ai surmonté will
chez juste suffocation ou et puis est
passé à nos pieds peux-tu humains des
bouquins discret mais peu toulouse
gérait ruinée dès 18h hier toujours
puceau delà sur certains jeux d'ici peu
égaré sur ses envies mairie leur sortie
vous vouliez vous vouliez aller sauver
votre femme ben oui mais quand j'ai eu
chaud t-il chef que même si j'étais trop
longtemps
pékin après la pollution c'est non elle
avait de la difficulté à se déplacer
oui les mecs à l'âge de 93 92 lyon vous
êtes un petit peu plus et que vous ça
vous fait de la peine encore aujourd'hui
je peux demander mieux de se baigner
[Musique]
le bilan définitif sera finalement de 32
morts et 22 rescapés parce que neuf mois
après la tragédie
quatre corps n'ont toujours pas été
identifiés
[Musique]
merci beaucoup à tous ceux et celles qui
nous transmettent leurs messages de
sympathie et de sport à travers le
québec
c'est aussi l'heure des bilans le chef
yvan charron estime avoir été à la
hauteur de la situation
on était quand les vers minuit quelques
quatre municipalités ont décollé ce
rempart terre par la spa rapport la
programme qe2 au muscat était de coller
et on était six faillites et pourtant la
carte d'appel est clair le chef a appelé
deux casernes dix minutes après avoir
été mise au courant du feu une troisième
sept minutes plus tard les 4e et 5e
caserne
le poste de commandement les humbles et
beaucoup plus tard
que ce soit pour les pompiers ou les
services de surveillance de la résidence
l'ancien chef conrad murray n'accepte
pas qu'on ait tant tardé à sauver les
gens
il est jacqueline goy fier mais y'a
personne tourner vers les îles même
samedi l'équipe font donner de lille
tient qu'aux d'un coût de ces niches
week-ends jours ci le je suis un mouton
13 juillet c'était tout enjeu c'est bon
greed 1 avenue à roger rien roger vadim
julien logeais de bouquins en parcourant
les documents que nous avons obtenu une
question se pose avec des invités
les pompiers de l'isle verte et est il
prêt à faire face à la situation
en lisant les dépositions des pompiers
on se rend compte que plusieurs d'entre
eux étaient en cours de formation pour
remplir les exigences du ministère la
sécurité publique y est donc considéré
comme apprenti certains n'auraient même
pas eu l'autorisation de pénétrer dans
le périmètre de sécurité du feu étant
donné leur niveau de formation
quand sont arrivés à cet incendie majeur
mais il travaillait fort les petits
gordy ont fait de bonnes choses
m'ayant fait mon job est en fait le leur
le grand possible mes shsh dois admettre
que ça prenait plus de personnel
institué et déco pas sa charge toutes
les semaines de temps domaine du feu
toutes les semaines depuis 2004 non
seulement les pompiers des petites
municipalités doivent avoir une
formation complète mais aussi leurs
officiers or les documents de la mrc où
se trouve l'île verte indique qu'aucun
permis ces quatre officiers avaient
effectué la formation d'officiers non
urbain se prévalant d'une clause
grand-père puisqu'ils sont en poste
depuis une salle fermée 18
c'est pas une excuse de le fait d'être
en région non non non le nom était pour
dire regardez on ici nous autres la
formation de moins parce que la loi et
la main propre au mont houy apprend le
seuil haut des gens qui donnent dans des
maisons on a bon état des bébés des
femmes pizzala il faut qu'ils protègent
s'ils peuvent pas le fabec idiot pas la
faire là portait d'uniforme
le chef qui vingt chars ont fait partie
des quatre physiques n'ont pas la
formation d'officiers non urbain son cas
est encore plus problématique puisque
selon nos vérifications il n'est pas
certain qu'il pourrait bénéficier de la
clause grimpeur ayant rompu son lien
d'emploi qu'en 2005 après avoir
démissionné de son poste pendant six
mois
ce qui était un avant cette histoire
c'est de voir que les mères qui ont
dirigé l'île verte avant le feu dit
qu'il n'était pas au courant que les
chercheurs ont hissé officiers n'avait
pas suivi la formation d'officiers dans
un milieu non urbain vous saviez que
votre chef n'avait pas de formation
déficit sylvain charron votre formation
d'officier vous savez ça non ce n'est
pas ça ce que vous saviez qu'il y avait
seulement quatre pompiers sur cèze qui a
une formation de pompier non saviez pas
ça non je vous soumettre ça se
connaissaient ce document là schéma de
couverture de risques en matière de
sécurité incendie
rivière-du-loup 2010-2015 a été déposée
en 2000
ce sens 2010 connaissait le document de
retraites adoptée chevaux oui ok alors
gardons aussi situation actuelle de la
sécurité syndi 2008 formation des
pompiers des officiers société sous
votre mandat
il verra nombre d'effectifs 16
officier ou équivalent compléter 0
officiellement urbain équivalent 0
officie l'information 0 bon qui valent 1
4 sa vie personne vous saviez pas que
votre chef n'avait pas de formation de
psy
mais
[Musique]
c'est chaque fois les pompiers je ne
peux croire que ce petit pays et des
gens qui habitent dans une petite ville
ont droit à la même sécurité qu'ailleurs
mais regardez-moi je suis arrivée là ils
étaient dix ans est mais je suis jamais
posé cette question nous
au moment de l' incendie les choses
s'étaient améliorées puisque quatre
autres pompiers étaient en formation
[Musique]
les indications feeling à l'exercice
c'était lundi dernier au conseil
municipal de l'île verte
la mairesse ursule thériault qui a été
élu quelques semaines avant les 110 2
janvier dernier avait de bonnes
nouvelles pour son chef de pompiers yvan
charron présents dans la salle
la municipalité h tra l'an prochain deux
nouveaux camions de pompiers et
augmentera aussi sa force de frappe
c'est une recommandation pour cautionner
la rose de nouveaux fonds qui voulons
des soirées jeux suivants se passe-t-il
pour information aline données il est
formé de a à z
les relations n'ont pas été toujours
aussi bonne dans le passé entre le chef
et dirigeants municipaux de l'île verte
ce que c'était facile de charron c'était
pas facile c'est pas toujours facile
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire mais le
service les services de pompiers et un
peu comme apport du conseil itf faisait
ses affaires puis il voulait pas trop
que le conseil se mêlent aux hommes de
coin genre dégoûterait pourtant de
parole un des anciens responsables du
comité incendie du conseil municipal
daniel gagnon avait lui aussi des
problèmes avec le chef charron c'était
malheureux des fois ils arrivaient bien
pompiers nouveau qui rentre et puis où
tu vois ce que je ferai en disant que ça
ne faisait pas sa tête puis soudain vu
du reste
[Musique]
sans les anciens conseillers disent
avoir à faire ou chef chars ont toute la
formation qu'il désirait pour lui et ses
hommes mais pas toujours avec succès on
ne peut pas forcer quelqu'un à l'est des
courses ils peuvent pas ou par le
travail ou par kolo barst mythique ainsi
peut pas y aller lors vous soyez si peu
voilée peut pas où il veut pour eux sont
pas jugés
les tensions étaient tellement grande
que selon certains membres de l'ancien
conseil municipal
les pompiers se sont ligués contre eux
pour appuyer l'équipe de la nouvelle
mairesse en 2013 mais où conseil de
cette semaine la question de la
formation des officiers des revenus sur
le tapis
les toqués de l'hiver sont certifiés
pour donner quand il voit surtout tout
démonter sont également formés - il ya
une clause qui s'appelle consacré à
résister d'embauché avant s'attendre 20
cette loser s'appelait qui fait que tu
aies légale par coup mais tous ne sont
pas d'accord avec monsieur charon mais
je pense que si aujourd'hui la loi dit
qu'il faut avoir les formations
devraient avoir des formations qu'est ce
qui est jeté a été pompier avant ou
après je pense que tu devrais avoir la
formation puis ça devrait plutôt sur la
capitelle lui qu'un qui était capitaine
lilia de démissionner l'autre but
rennais chef le chef pompier qu'un
séchoir démissionner il ya pas du tout
si ça grâce cessons de mes cinq années
missionné par un jour ce sera devant les
questions de l'assemblée du conseil de
lundi soir et des explications du chef
chavent la mairesse thériault a louangé
le travail des pompiers lors de la
tragédie du 23 janvier l'association
oui
après l'assemblée le chef charron s'est
expliquée notamment sur sa formation
la formation je suivais les années les
compagnies officiers ça mais je n'étais
pas dans l'obligation de subir comme ça
car j'ai eu presque une vingtaine de
minutes s'étaient écoulées
aujourd'hui entre le thonier
poignée de main
comment vous combien victime en lui même
des livres la première demande d'entre
elles
savoir où est-ce que ça avait pu être
humain 2 est en cale tout ce qui est à
calais d'un des dix c'est une erreur en
annonçant que les premiers contenus sont
arrivés lancés c'était une boule de feu
de charbon dit la sarre charlebois
nous avons payé tout fait
oui c'est vrai j'ai ça recommence agir
pour la même chose si le show oui oui
ça serait juste une personne un sombre
est à minutes l'eau s'avère
malencontreuse bien mais si on perd le
chef d'un fonds
qui va sauver opel
il ya nos dossiers la mairesse de son
côté a été avare de commentaires la
formation de ce bon chiffre initial aux
grands palaces qui a répondu aux
questions de formation qui selon vous
fait faire fait si vous parlez de sauce
et bien vous donner les réponses vous
les avez gpo a ajouté ce que mangeaient
janvier à la grande question que tout le
monde se pose ici comment faire pour
éviter pareille tragédie
surtout dans une région où la sécurité
de la plupart des municipalités est
assurée par des pompiers volontaires
c'est le cas de saint louis du ha ha où
l'ancien chef conrad murray à une
caserne en son honneur monsieur morin
vit aujourd'hui dans une résidence de
rivière du loup où il accroché au mur
la seule photo de lui de sa femme qu'on
a retrouvés dans les décombres
celle de leur mariage oui j'ai vu je
t'aime sylvie répond je demandais si je
suis sidéré s'oublie il dit ça s'oublie
beau faut apprendre à vivre avec
[Musique]